よろしいですか はい これから仏教の解説なんですけど
まあ今までも仏教的な見方なんですけど
まあいくらか現代的な分析で
これから仏教は自信ということはどう見るのかっていうね
自信に対して正と邪というものはあるんでしょうかと
正しい自信と正しくない自信というものをね
まあ一応自信という単語がないということは説明しましたけど
そこら辺には今日はそんなに
自信ということをね セルフコンフィデンス
自信というのは まあ仏教からいうと意味はね
確実にできる 成功する
間違うはずはない 期待する結果は必ず出るという確信なんですよ
自信というのは それを覚えてほしいんです
自信って何なのかというと
まあ確実にできるということ
成功するということ 間違いないんだと
これでよしと  これでは期待通りの結果が出るんですよ
出ますよということなんです
であるならば 自信なんかはありえない話ですよ
1番目はわかるでしょうね
別に納得するでしょうに
自信というのはそういうものだから
もし自信はそういうものであるならば
自信なんかはありえないんです
当たり前の話ですよ これは本当です
冗談でもないんです 自信なんかはないんです
世の中 じゃあもう一度上に戻ってみてください
何か確実にできるって確信できますか？できないでしょうに
必ずしも成功するという確信できないでしょうに
ということは 自信というのはありえないんです
なくてよかったですね
自信があると言えば これは要注意なんですよ
では 自信がない方がいいんですかね
この問題 これは微妙ですよ
答えは 自信があるはずもないと言ったところで
ではない方がよかったんでしょうかというと
これまた微妙 心の汚れ
煩悩のせいで自信がなくなったり
過剰自信になったりすると以前説明しました
今まで自信がないケースと過剰自信のケースをずっと説明したでしょうに
その中にあったのは心の煩悩なんですね
妄想することはものすごい大事な煩悩でしょうに
すべての煩悩をまとめると妄想なんですよ
と感情 だからもう妄想と感情で言われる煩悩があるんだから
自信がないんだから 自信なくてよかったと言っちゃうと
煩悩を溶かさなくちゃいけないんですよ
心は来てなくて まあいいんじゃないんですかと言わなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
従って自信がないは悪ですよ
だって自信がないということは煩悩があるということだから
自信がない生き方は全部悪なんです
しかし 自信があるは善だと無批判にするのではありません
反対はなりたくないんですよ
この般若心経みたいな
その失敗はしないでほしいんです
で 自信がないは悪なんですけど
だったら自信があるのは善でしょ
では違うんです 何でもかんでも逆になるわけじゃないんです
色即成 色即成空と言った途端
空即成色にはなりませんよ
ですから それはブッダの答えなんです
理性的な自信 正しいのは理性的な自信なのです
自信がと理性がありまして
一緒でしょうかと 一切は因縁によって起こるもので
また無常なのです 確実なものはありません
この世の中で一つも この因縁というのはすごい大事なことで
もうすぐ変わるというね
しかし 具体的に客観的に情報状況などを観察すると
結果の推測ができますよ
例えば  3ヶ月後とかで受験あるんだと
これぐらいのことを勉強しなくちゃいけないんだと
だったらきちんと分けて
1 日こんなこれぐらい時間勉強すれば
これぐらい量を理解すればまあ合格するだろうという計画は合理的に立てられるでしょうに
また条件を変えることで
木を取れば  うん 結果を期待通りにすることも可能です
それ因果法則のありがたいところなんですよ
例えば ある木があって
木の実はおいしいんだけど
すごく小さいんだと それだったらいろいろ因果法則を変えると大きな木の実にすることはできるでしょうに
で それから日本はもう何でも外国から輸入するんですけど
ヘリクツだからいろんな一部の品物は輸入しないことにする
それに人をもうマインドコントロールする
一つの例はさくらんぼ
さくらんぼはどこでもあるんですけど
あれかなり何色でしたっけ？あれは
このすごい真っ赤なまあ色なんですけど
真っ赤というもうあの
ちょっと黒に近いぐらい
しかし 日本のさくらんぼはピンク色でしょ
それで日本人はピンク色のさくらんぼの方がいいと暗示かけられてるんです
さくらんぼはピンク色じゃないんですよ
そういう風に作るんです
日本で 薄い色ですごくきれいな可愛いピンク色に作るんです
それも太陽の日の当たり方がいろいろ管理して
満遍なく同じ色になるように結構工夫する
それでもうものすごく値段かかっちゃうんです
それで売ってくれます
買ってくれませんだからもうマインドコントロール攻撃に行くんです
だからなんでさくらんぼの色を変えられ
ただアメリカから輸入するさくらんぼはすごく違うでしょうに
別の種類が変わってるわけじゃないんです
同じものです だからこれは因果法則なんですよ
因果法則だからもう決まってないんですよ
黄色に近いさくらんぼを作ろうと思ったら
それもできるんですよ
研究によって 例えば すごい色がたくさんある花が
何花でしたっけ？チューリップとかね
昔 小説まであるんだからね
いろんな色のチューリップの花を咲かせるということで
なんでそれできるのかというと
やっぱり条件変わると結果が変わりますよ
だから理性がなかったらできませんよ
自分好きな色の花が咲かせようと思っても
もうこれは無知な人にできないんだからね
ただ種を植えて水をあげただけで
期待通りにはこないんですよ
だから必要なのは理性なんですよ
例えば いろんな花を作ったり
野菜作ったり いろんなものを作ったりする人々は
いろいろ条件を変えて変えて試してはいる
必ずしも期待通りに結果出るということはないんだけど
結構理性があると 物事を知っているとうまくいくんですよ
だから自信があるかないかどうでもいいんだから
必要なのは自分がやることはちゃんと理解しているのかっていうことなんです
すべて無常だから 因縁だから
理性的な自信 すべてをうまくいっても
予測しなかったことが起きて
状況や結果が変わる可能性もあります
これは世間のことなんですよ
すべてうまくいっても
またどこかで あの どこでしたっけ？このみかんですよ
で もうあの収穫するちょっと前に
1日  2日  1週間ぐらい前に
地震かもうなんとかあって
もう全部落ちちゃったんですね
何の問題もないんですよ
みかんはすごく立派で
もうもう収穫するその時期になっていたんです
だから 落ちる場合は木はすごく丁寧に落とすんですよ
ヘタから綺麗に外して
すごくかっこいいんですよ
木から外れるんだから
木が落とすんだからね
でも売れないんだって
ヘタがないと 味も形も色も何も変わらない
だから大損なんですよ
このオレンジ オレンジですよ
作った人々はすべてうまくいったんですよ
収穫する ちょっと 3日 4
日前でちょこっと視線が変わって
大損 だから日本の店で
あの ヘタがついて ヘタというんですか？あの房
何て言いますか え？へたでいい
あれ付いてないと売れないってどういうわけ？これって何やんの？思いますけど
だって あのメロンの場合でも
綺麗にあの枝があるとえらい高いこと
8,000円  9 1万円とかね
バカじゃないか あれにお金払ってるんだから
私は大変もらえてとこで箱ごとに買ったことありますよ
あのメロンを 箱丸ごと
もう 1,500円とかに
もうもう運べないんだから
もう 2つに1個買うんだったら
もう一つ持っていきなさいというんです
味には何の変わりもないんです
取ったばっかりだから結構美味しいんです
しかし 店には出せないんだって
あれ？あれがないんだ
だからそれ切れるところもあって
このまま植物は自然だから
いろんなところで勝手に育ちますから
そこで切っちゃうと全部なくなる場合もありますから
その場合はあれだけ取っちゃうんですよ
前もっと大きいものがあるんだったら
それはヘタと一緒に切っておこうかなと思って
ですから そういうものも結構出ます
それはすごく安く売らなくちゃ値上げになるんです
で こういう辺に住んでいる人々はむっちゃあのお金払わなくちゃいけないんだ
ヘタにメロンはもう 8,000円で空いてる枝には8,000円じゃなくても
もう一応 1,000円ぐらいで空いてる枝には残り 8,000円と
だからいかにマインドコントロールされているのかということも考えてください
いかに無知なアホなことをやっているのかと
自然はいかに破壊しているのかと
だから資源が足りなくて
物事足りなくて困っているでしょうに
こんな国でもうもうもう食べ物がすごく珍しいっていうのはどういうことかと
これほどもう世界でどこにもないほど立派な土地でしょうに
世界でもないんですよ
日本の土地みたいな この栄養豊かな
植物は勝手に育てる 土っていうのは
だから頭の問題ですよ
そういうことだから いくら状況がうまくいっても
最後の最後でちょこっとこじれる
こじれるっていうこともありますよ
ですから 理性に基づいて可能性を図るんですよ
成功ではなくて この可能性
プロバビリティーということは
みかん畑作るんだったら
まあどれぐらい可能なのかと
確実性は決してありえないんです
確実性はもうもう絶対ありえないんで
それだけは可能性ですよ
まあこれやってこれやって
こういうふうに条件があって
こういうふうな状況だったらこうなるでしょうと
ということで 自信がある人もない人も
改めて可能性をチェックする人間にならなくてはならない
だから問題は あなたが自信があるかないか
自信がないんだったら自信つけてあげるぞとかね
とんでもない話なんですよ
人間に自信があってもなくてもどうでもいいんです
あなたは行動するときはそこと可能性をチェックしているのかと
まあ良い結果が出る可能性
それだけで十分仕事できますよ
これ曲一つ作ってこれをヒットさせてやるぞとかね
これだったらありえないんですよ
もうもう何も浮かべなくなっちゃうんですよ
だからヒットするかしないかどうではなくて
まあまあヒットすればありがたいと
とにかくヒットする場合は
一般的には聞きやすいこと
メロディは覚えやすいこと
頭に残ること あの音は三小みたいな感じで
いくつかの条件がありますよ
このヒットする歌の場合は
それで詩もみんな英語の単語を入れたり
わけもわからないくっだらないこと書いてるでしょ
売れないんですよ 詩も普通の日本語で滑らかに流れるっていうこと
ただ単に格好つけて英語やらギリシャやラテン語たらもう全部間違いなんで
もう単語ばっかし入れちゃって
あんなのもう文学的にはもうダサいのところなんです
もうヒットしないんですよ
SMAPのなんか大事になってるの
何でしたっけ？あの歌は
世界のたった一つの花とかなんとかありますね
で そういうあれ タイトルだけでもなんか
いい気分になります 一回だけでも聞いて聞こうかなと思ってますけどね
チャートの第1位になってますよ
もう2年も経ってるのに SMAP
っていうのはそんなに歌が上手なグループじゃないんですけどね
だから笑いやらいろんなことをやって仕事を頑張ってます
お金がないと生きていられませんだから
歌はまあほとんどもう上手とはね
まあ言えないんですけどね
でもあの 死でね 死はそれなりに立派っていうことになってくるとヒットする
だから 曲を作る人はそういうヒットする条件を考えて
またいろいろ思う 考えてやればいいんで
でもヒットするかしないか
そんなの分かったもんじゃないんですけどね
だから可能性だけチェックすればもう頑張れるんですよ
可能性が高いほどやるやる気が出るんですよ
これ 仏教ではチャンダというんですよ
可能性が高いなと言っちゃうと
もうやらせていられなくなっちゃうんで
誰でも自信があるかないかは関係なくなっちゃうんですよ
これはもしかすると可能だなとわかるとやる気が出ます
まあチャンダは欲というふうに訳しますけど
これは欲という意味じゃないんです
だからこのチャンダ 何でしょうかね
もう欲 他の言葉がないんですね
まあやりたいという気持ちなんですね
やりたい やりたいと 別に欲じゃないんです
だからやる気なんですよ
チャンダっていうのは
その気になる やる気になる
それから行動すること
やる気になったらやればいいでしょうに
やる気になったら言わなくてもやるでしょうに
それでお釈迦様はチャンダンジャーとウッサハティ
欲が生まれた人はそれから頑張るんだよと
何のことなのか 自然に
自然に しかし 結果通りの計画通りの結果が出なくても
それは因果法則と無常ということで管轄外ですよ
やる気が出て 可能性もかなりあってやったんだからといって
結果はもう知らん 自分だけのことじゃないんだから
結果は だから結果は自分を気にすることじゃない
これは自分と管轄外なんです
自分はもうそこでやればいいっていうことです
可能性あるんだから やる気もあるんだから
やることも楽しいんですよ
やる気がないと楽しくないんですよ
結果が変わった原因は自分にならないようにと努めることですね
自分のせいで良い結果が出た出なかったと言っちゃうとまずいでしょう
だからやる気出した 自分は自分の原因だけはぴったしと自分でやることをちゃんとやる
結果はもう自分との管轄外だと
私のせいで 私はちょっと手抜いたんだから
こんな結果になったと言っちゃうと
これは最悪ですよ だから
いろんな原因があって良い結果が出るんですから
その中で自分の行動という原因だけはしっかりする
結果は管轄外だと 悪い結果になったっても悲しくはないんです
理性的な自信で 可能性は五分五分でも
理性的な自信の場合はやってみる価値はあるんですよ
どう調べたっても 可能性は五分五分やと
でもやってみる価値があるんですよ
五分五分だから もしうまくいく可能性はありますよ
5%より低くてもやってみる価値はありますよ
例えばこの何か家の中でカップとかなんとかでリンゴを実れるのかと
カップの中だったら無理でしょうね
だから無理ということはもう 99%でしょ
でも 1%ぐらい もしかするとあるでしょう
やってみたら別にいいんじゃないですか
別に 種を植えて それなりに面倒を見てあげてみれば
もしリンゴの種 これ実ったらこれすごい楽しいし
ダメ ダメでしたねと それで終わるでしょうね
別に だから50より低くたっても可能性はね
やってみる価値はありますよ
なぜならば 可能性100であっても
結果は必ずということないんだからね
とにかくやらないでいるよりはやってみた方が価値があるんですよ
で 俺サンスクリット語にも言葉があるみたいんですよ
で 結果気にして何もやらない人は非難されると
社会で認めるか認めないかどうでもいいんだけど
自分のことはちゃんとやっておいた方が
その人の方は立派であると
自分の仕事はもうビシビシとやると
というのは まあインド文化でも言われる言葉さあるみたいし
同じことを仏教は認めるんですね
結果だけは自分一人で決めるものではないんだからね
そんなことで 今日のテーマにしたっても同じことで
皆様が考えていない自信ということは
仏教の中で扱ってみるとかなりきついんですよ
単純な面白い話にはなりません
もうビシビシときめ細かく分析するんですね
だから それ私は手を抜いちゃうと
私にとってはすごい気分が悪いんですよ
それは大体普通のお坊さんたちにはもうほとんど無理だと思いますし
だから私が自分の仕事をやっていかなきゃいけないんです
だから理解できるないか
それは別々よ あまり私は気にしない
それで自信の比率でしょうかね
可能性が高いほど やる気
意欲が高くなるんですね
それが自信というとしましょうと
あまり自信という言葉を使った方が良くないんですよ
やる気 自信ではなくて
だから今日から心の中からこの自信という言葉を使わないで
やる気ということにしてみてください
やる気だったらなんとかしてやる気出せますよ
それで可能性が高いんだったら
当然やる気がある 可能性が低くなっちゃうと
やる気 やる気も減っていくんですが
やりなさいっていうのは我々の言い方なんです
可能性は低くなるとその分意欲も減る
意欲は減ることは無気力
怠けになるのは危険なので
それで可能性が低い カップルの中でリンゴの実を乗ってみ乗ってみようかなと言ったら
これは可能性はね  1 もないでしょうね
そうなるとやる気がなくなっちゃうでしょうね
このやる気がなくなること
危ないんですよ だって無気力になるんだから
怠けになるんだから だから可能性は低くても
意欲を保つことはできます
無気力はダメ 怠けはダメ
危険と思えば とにかくもうもううまくいかないのはもう 80%ですけど
やってみるんだと 自信とはやる気の度合いだけのことですよ
自信 仏教的に言えばね
自信というのはやる気の度合いの問題なんですよ
そんなもん 比率といってもどういったことはないんですよ
可能性とも比率しているだけ
理性があるならば あるなら
正義があるなら正しいもので
ない場合は邪ですよ やる気も
だから自信には正と邪があるんです
ちょっと直して それをよく覚えてください
正しい自信 正しくない自信ということがあるんです
自信という単語を使いませんだからこれからはもう正しいやる気と正しくないやる気っていうのはあるんです
それで正しいと正しいのはどうやって決めますかね
理性で決めるんですよ
例えば人を殺すことにやる気があるんだと
それは正しくないと これは誰にでも言えるでしょうに
やる気を出して強盗するんだと
これはダメやというのはどうこうなんて誰にでもできますからね
でも ブッダにしか言えないことはこれです
強盗はもうやる気出してするのは良くないということは
もう誰にでも言えることで
これにはブッダがなくても大丈夫です
だから成果じゃか決めるのは理性で決めるんです
だから強盗して金儲かることは理性的じゃないでしょうに
それで道徳は守り神になってくるんです
やる気は必ずしも正で正で正しいやる気
やる気がある それはいつでも正しいという確固たる状況を作るためには
道徳というのは守り神になるんですよ
だから これは自信の保険なんです
それは保険かけてほしいんです
自身に やる気に 心の基盤は道徳であるならば
活発性 やる気 意欲は決して失わないんですよ
気持ちの基盤は道徳的だったら
もういつでもやる気でいられるんです
いつでも明るいんですよ
きっとぶん殴ってやろうかなとかね
あいつの足を引っ張ってやろうかなと思っちゃうと
ひどい男でしょうね やる気がなくなったりするんです
自信が失ったりする 常に明るく元気で
活発に落ち込みがなく生きていられますよ
道徳基盤だったら 心の基盤は
貪瞋痴に汚れた欲は悪で危険なのです
簡単になくなるし 自分も他人も胸を張って評価しないんですよ
例えば 怒り 欲でやる気が出たとしても
すぐ壊れますよ そのやる気が
例えばむっちゃ欲張って仕事をすると
もう金の亡者で金儲かりますけど
本人もどこかで後ろめたさ感じるんですね
周りも あの人成功はしているんだけど
人間としてはどうかなというでしょうね
社会ではあまり認めないでしょう
だから貪瞋痴のやる気っていうのは危ないんですよ
簡単に壊れてしまいます
それ悪ですよ 罪です 一切の行為は
1.自分のためになるか
2.他人のためになるか
3.すべての生命のためになるかと行為をする前に客観的に観察するんですよ
何かやる前に これは私のためになるか
周りのためになるか 一般的な人のためになるものかと
これが道徳の基盤なんですよ
貪瞋痴はあまりわかりにくいんだからね
これでわかりやすいんですよ
だからちょこっと結果を推測するんですよ
この結果は私のためになるのか
周りの人々の幸せになるのか
世間一般的に悪いことではなく
みんなの役に立つことかと
まだやってないんだから
まあちょこっと誤認する
間違った判断する可能性もありますよ
だって人間なもんだからね
あり得るから 行為をする時も気をつけて観察する
そこで仕事をやっている時でも観察しているんですよ
誤認する恐れがあるんです
それでも判断間違いはあるかもしれません
やっている真っ最中でも
ですから 行為終わってからも観察する結果を
その時はぴったし判断できますよ
もう結果があるんだからね
これがダメでしたとかね
みんなのためになったんですけど
私にとっては最悪やとかね
そういうふうに判断は後でできますけど
これを何の役に立つかというと
次の行動に役に立つんです
だから やる前に やってる時とやってからも観察をしなくちゃいけないんです
それって難しいんだったら
一番楽な方法は慈しみ
慈しみの気持ちでそれに生きることはより簡単な方ですよ
あーごちゃごちゃ考えればややこしい
難しい 貪瞋痴あるのかないのかとは分かったもんじゃないでしょうしね
正直なところは 行動する前にしている
している時 終わってから判断する方がね
これは結構難しいんですよ
だったら簡単なのは慈しみでいる
結果を推測したりすることで困ることもなくなる
気持ちは慈しみだったら結果を気にすることはないんです
間違い 失敗は稀にしか起こりません
気持ちは慈しみだったら間違いはなし
人生は まあ万が一 1 1万人
1億分の1ぐらいはもうちょこっとした失敗あるかもしれませんだけど
そんなのは別に だからほとんど間違いない人生はできますよ
慈しみで 仏教でいう自信は活発性を徐々に向上させることです
そこで仏教は自信というか
やる気というか それは徐々にどんどんどんどん向上させなくちゃいけないんですね
で 終わります これだから最後のところはちょこっと自信があっただけでは足りません
さらにさらに上上を目指していかなくちゃいかない
仏教は悟りということを教えているんだから
あの煩悩をなくす過程になってくると
結構勇気が必要ですよ
だから我々今持っているやる気をさらにさらに育てて磨き上げなくちゃいけない
それが危なくなりますから
道徳の基盤がないと だから慈しみということを基盤にして
より活発に より友好的に
より明るくというふうに生きていかなくちゃいけないんですね
ということで 話は終了で
どうもありがとうございます
まだ少し時間がございますけど
今のお話へのご質問など
お手もありますけど  いいですか
うん 可能性が高いと  100%これはできるというようなものには
当たり前すぎてあまりやる気が起きなくて
むしろ可能性が低いけどやってみたいなというようなこともあるんじゃないかなと思うので
やる気っていうのは可能性だけで出るんじゃなくて
なんかもっと違う要素があるんじゃないかなっていうふうにも思うんですけど
その点はどうでしょう
ああ それは単語はどう理解するかっていうこと
と思いますけど 単語はいろいろ勝手に理解できますからね
いや 可能性が百パーセントあるにも関わらず
やれやらないっていう人間って
そういう人もいます  まあ具体的にまあいないわけ
まあいる可能性はありますけどね
それはこういうケースなんですよ
いや 面白くないんだと
どうせできるんだからと
もうちょいとできないことに挑戦しようとかね
ということだから すごいやる気があるんですよ
結局は 例えば早稲田大学ならもうもういとも簡単に目を閉じたっても合格できそうという
100パーセント自信がある人は
早稲田ではなくて もっと難しい大学に挑戦するとかね
それはもともとやる気があるんですよ
だから言ってる通りで
可能性は １００なのに６０に挑戦したっていうことになるんですね
それは別に悪いことじゃないんですよ
でも やる気がない人にとっては
もう そこはそうなるのかと
やる気がない人は可能性が 100なのにもやらないんだったら
60 には挑戦しないでしょう
例えばできないんだからやるぞっていうことを
すごいやる気なんですよ
どちらかというと 私の個人的にもそういう性格的なところはありましたから
もうできないと言わないと挑戦しないんです
これは難しいやとかね
できるわけないんだと
言うとやる気が出てくるんですよ
それちょこっと性格的なもので
初めからもやる気があるんですよ
そうすると誰にもできることはやらないんです
もうちょこっといいことに挑戦する
そういうことで 自分のやる気もまたさらに向上します
可能性と別にやる気っていう
そういう気持ちっていうのがあるってことですか
それはもう性格的にね
ありますね やる気がないということは
怠けとかね 無知とかね
妄想とかね あんまりごちゃごちゃになってくると浪費しますから
エネルギーはね 別に自然にやる気があるんですよ
物事は止まらないし 心も止まらないし
だからずっと活発になった方が気分がいいんですよ
それで妄想することでエネルギーを浪費するんだから
活発性がなくなっちゃって
それを仏教は悪というんですね
だからやる気ない人っていうのは
もう激しく妄想しているんですね
それですごく漏電しているんです
妄想しない場合は明るくて
例えば子供はすごい明るいでしょうね
もうあまり妄想する悩み事っていうのはほとんどないでしょうね
すごい元気なんです それが妄想するデータがどんどん溜まってくると
もう元気じゃないし やる気もなくなっちゃうんですね
大体子供の場合はもうほとんど
13 4 になってくるともう危ないでしょう
突然学校を辞める可能性もあるし
もう引っ込んじゃう可能性もある
一番体力があって元気で可愛い年なんですけど
あれでも結構大人の社会のことやらいろんなデータ知ってますよ
それで妄想しちゃうんですね
全部やる気がなくなっちゃうんです
この子供を育てるときは
かなり誰でもその問題にぶつかっちゃいますよ
突然やる気が出せなくなるというね
日本では結構ある問題で
普通は思春期っていうのは反抗期だから手に負わない時期なんですよ
もう親に逆らうわ 言うこと聞かないわ
もう出て行ったらなかなかもうご飯の時間には帰ってこないわとかね
なんで遅くなったんで
どこ行ったんですか？って言うと
それに怒るわとかね それだったらすごい健康的で正しいんですよ
子供は反抗期でかなり反抗するんだったらすごく正しいんですけど
もうやる気を失ってるわけじゃないんです
もう家にいるのはつまらなくて
親の言うことを聞くのはつまらなくて
とにかく反抗してみたいというね
で 引っ込みになっちゃうと
これは危ないんですよ
危ない 良くないんですね
とにかく それが漏電状態ですね
いろんなことをごちゃごちゃ考えて
先生 あの やってみなきゃわからないというのは
最初の時はあんまり肯定的な言葉じゃなかったと思うんですが
後の方で理性的に行って結果は
判断にはないという これ大事
これもやっぱり結果はわかる
わからん  やってみればわかる
その場合は単語ちょっと違う
やってみる価値があると
挑戦だからね だからやってみなきゃわからないじゃなくて
やってみてもわからないんだからね
本当は 挑戦する価値がある
うまくいったらいいんだからね
後の後の方 それは仏教は推薦する方ですね
子どもが逡巡している時に
やってみなきゃわかんないじゃないかっていう後押しするっていうのはプラスのこと
それはマイナスでしょうね
やってみなければわからないぐらい
それぐらい子どもは知ってますよ
もう俗世間の無知な考え方だから
やる価値があるんだよと
挑戦する価値があるんだよと
何ででも それが子どもは知らないんだよ
子どもは知らないことを教えてあげないと
やってみなきゃわからんでしょっていうのは
これはもうどんな馬鹿に言いますよ
そんなことを大人が子どもに言ったっても
聞いてくれるはずがないんです
うるさいと 知らないことを言うと聞いてくれます
だからやってみなきゃわからないはアウトダメで
やってみる価値がある
それが OK です はい  問題があったものもわかりますけど
あの 20数年前はものすごい学園運動がありまして
若いたちがもうバーッと燃えて
何もあの何かするような感じで活動してましたけども
今は全然それがなくて
無関心 無責任 無気力っていうような言葉がよく言われる
隣の国ではものすごい若いたちがものすごい運動
反日運動をとか そういう
それは大体 どういうことなんでしょうか
うん ね そこはね だからこれはもう一概にこれこれっていうことはちょっと言えないんですけど
ただ単に反対運動やったりデモやったりとかね
攻撃的にやるということのすごい危険なところはありますよ
ものすごい暗示されやすい
特にこの宗教の問題で恐ろしいでしょうしね
まるっきり無知なことに元気で攻撃して戦うでしょ
でも物を壊したり 学校を壊したりとかね
そこはえらい迷惑で やってはいけないことで
だからといって若者は元気でなければ
まあどんでもない それまた危険なんですよ
そこで例えば日本の社会になってくると
ああいう激しい過激的な行動は良くないんだということは
子供たちにずっと言い伝えてしまって
それでやらなくなっちゃったんですね
それで無気力 無関心状態になってしまったんですね
私から言えば どちらでも正しくないんだと
元気で明るくて それなりのいいことに挑戦する
社会の悪いことなんとあったら
ビシビシとそれを 理的にいろいろあれやこれやとデータ集めたりして
講演やったり いろいろ署名集めて反対運動やったりとか
それなりに行動するのはすごくありがたいですよ
だからといって暴力で物を壊したりっていうのはね
もう単なるもう無知で感情で
これは認めることもできないし
私たちは平和主義で別に興味ないっていうのはものすごくダメですよ
それではもうリーダーたちは出てこないんだからね
子供たちからは だからそこはもうまあ難しいんですよ
この仏教の教えがない世界だから
どこでもね 世の中で だからどうすればいいかとわからない
例えば日本は過激的なことは良くないと決めちゃって
出すだけスローンでみんな無力
無関心になってしまったんですね
今それに困っているでしょうに
そうすると何かごちゃごちゃ大人が言うでしょうね
また 次の世代はあまりにも過激的で攻撃的になる可能性あります
あのイラクで捕まれたら
なんとか人が平気で人殺しに行っていたでしょうに
日本でできないんだから
合法的に だからやっぱりこれでなきゃあれというよね
もうもうもうどちらでも悪い極端なんですよ
だからより理性的で より道徳的で
そういうことに挑戦 例えば
日本の若者たちが社会福祉福祉活動をやるとかね
みんな揃って何々大学の何々活動とかね
大いに大げさにやれば
やらなきゃあかんぞと
そうするともう国内でやるクラブやら
外国でやるクラブやらとかいっぱい出るでしょうに
そうなっちゃうと社会に興味があるでしょうに
そうすると社会の不正なことにしたっても
ごちゃごちゃ文句言えるでしょうに
若者に言える文句っていうのは
一応それなりに問題も起こしませんだからもう聞いてあげることはできるでしょうに
もう大人がもう権力者が言っちゃうと
これはすごく問題起こります
そういうわけで もっとより道徳的な方法へ持っていった方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますね
人間というのは心理知らないんだから
一つの悪いことをやめると
その代わりに別な悪いことに置き換えるんですよ
それは人間の世界なんですね
だから人間には真理は何やということを考えられません
今日の自信というて 自信過剰のテーマにしたっても
ブッダから見るとそんなもんですよ
かなりきめ細かい すごい科学的にもう握ってます
そこまでは人間は考えませんよ
例えば心理学者やらね
お医者さんやら これ自信ない人にいろんなアドバイスするでしょうね
でもそこね アドバイスできないでしょうね
だからその場でブッダの答えは自信なんかはクソくらいどうでもいいやということでね
やる気やと問題は すごいシンプルですよ
それで問題はやる気があったっても
危ないことやりだしたらどうするのかと
どうやって正しいか悪いかわからないでしょうではわからないではないかと
だったら優しさやと 常に思いやりのある優しい人間になれと
そうしちゃうと問題は起きませんよと
優しい人間だったら虫にも悪いことしないでしょうに
でもやる気があるんだから何とかやる
やることは決して生命にも邪魔にはならないというね
そこでもぴっしゃりと最終的な結論を出すんですよ
仏教は だからそこは勉強した方がいいと
私は散々言えばそういうわけなんですよ
俗世間ではもういくら頑張ってもこの答えは出てこないんですよ
ものすごく難しい はい
自分のやる気 今の話ですけど
やる気を見てみると 一つの仕事にしても
例えば動機が道徳や慈しみの気持ちに基づいている部分と
それとそれと同じことなんですけども
実際それが自分がいい格好したいとか
見栄とかそういう基づいている部分と
モチベーションとしては両方混ざっているように感じるんですけれども
そういうことはどういうふうに考えたらいいでしょう
それもまあいいといえば自然ですけど
自然ともちょっと言いにくいのは
ほとんどこの道徳的な部分というのは
人間の場合はすごく少ないんですよ
見栄張ったり 自分のためになんとかっていうところの方がすごく多いんですけどね
で 混ざっているのは普通で言えば自然なんですよ
それでわかってほしいのは
この自分のために道徳的な部分じゃなくて
自分の欲とかね 自分の見栄張るとかね
いい格好をしたいとかね
そういう動機の場合は結構危険性があって
すぐやる気がなくなっちゃうとかね
嫌な気持ちになるとか
やけになるという危険性がいつでもありますよ
道徳的な場合はなかなかそうならないんですよ
道徳的な部分の場合はやけになることもないし
落ち込むこともないんですね
だからどんどんあの仕事でも何でもかんでも慈しみの方にどんどん広げた方がいいんですよ
仕事もいい格好をしてみんなに褒めてやるためにやるそうではなくて
みんなに必要なことをやるんだよと
私はそういうふうにやります
例えば これ 私は何でも知ってるぞといい格好をつけるためにやったわけじゃないんです
今日の講演では みんな全部あまりにも複雑すぎて理解しないかもしれませんだけど
データとしてゆっくりでも何回何回でも勉強しちゃうと
これはわかりますよと
それで私はブッダの教えをほんのわずかなチョコだけ言っておくと
これは失礼やと だからせっかくのチャンスだから
二度と来ないんだから
一応ブッダの教えを現代語に現代思考に入れ替えてやる仕事は完璧にやるんだと
でも 完璧というのは自分勝手な考え方なんですけど
もっとデータありますけど
まあちょっといろいろ絞らなくちゃいけないんだからね
だから それでは私は見栄張るつもりは全くないんです
いい格好つけるつもりもないんです
たまに言ったりはするんですけど
これはあくまでもふざけて遊んでるだけ
見栄張ったりする場合は
何の見栄だなくただふざけている
だからこの仕事をする場合は
慈しみで まあ自分にとっては精一杯
ギリギリの力で仕事をしてあげると
それで慈しみにするんですよ
みんなによく認めてもらっても
別に格好いいやと思ってもらっても
それはそちらの勝手で
というふうに この道徳の方が広げた方がいいと思いますよ
なぜならば 非道徳のところは危ないんです
やる気があってもガクンと落ちたりするんです
やる気が それが悪いんですよ
これがまた自信なくなるということにつながっちゃうんです
それでよろしいですか